みなさんこんにちはう
始め冊をの
強い清涼ん
今日はですねまぁちょっとゲストのお二方にしてもらってるんですけども強い書くわけ
ない彼はこの2人でちょっと
地区しかないんですけども月は僕の怖い話を
2人に聞いてもらおうという企画でございますよろしくお願いしますよろしく
滑ったら滑ったといい県
こちらのノートの本
2強く集されている病院に行こうと思います
宜しくお願いします
土中意味合いをしているか
いただきます
暗くて見えます関平快適飛倉フィーネ
俺の先輩から
聞いた話なんだけどそのせいか言わないから多分他の誰かから聞いたという話だからの
ツアージャパン話かは違うけどまぁそういう話が僕も聞いたという
男の人は2人右端に中
56歳とかのスポットの男の人が二人
車で幽霊が出ると言われ
エルトンで目に行きます3
りっ子なんか気に
これもよく行くんだけどずっと限りで第2子について加えているから
だったんだけどクラブはなかった
をトンネルにつけます
ユスカーってトコロ
留め金が入ったんだけど日結構長いトンネルで
何おそらくなかったんです
くらい飛んでる面の号数
なんでじゃいかんじゃないかな飛んで行ったんだけど突然
[音楽]
中間地点くらいである
止まるとか馬ガソリンがある
燃料切ったわけではないんだけどなぜか
エンジンかからんやばいやばいまずデータで食べてきたなるかな
中国タイで操作は捨てて
外テレビ関して飛んだりが長いから降りるわけにいかないから
どうしようどうしようって話で行ったときどう
就任
天井の上か
大学強いクルマに大分ようなん
二人の男はもうビビッというわけ
なんだんっ
なんだけど運転していた男の人が欠航する心理ゲーションが好きでや匹たという
ちょっとと笑う感じになった感じん
楽しい感じ来たいなみたいなキャ
て1
に質問するといい
絶対目に今いるから始動してみません
誰かいますか
そしたらドーン
返事みたいな感じでまたてに多く高騰が帰っていドン
続けて
幽霊ですか
ドン
いやー1419敗を守った
杉内と性別聞いてみるわ
男ですか
豚
男だ
男の幽霊感じる上
でも
どんどん質問してほとんど返すことがあるかもしれないか
念のために
ちょっと女のですかって聞いてみよう
女ですか
どーん
とこどんなと一つ持ってたから
ん
何が何でも丼って言われちゃう
私違うんじゃないかと思う
質問
何いますか
ああああああ
[音楽]
作者言えばん
ねぇ
ますちょっとね俺の声話はね怖い話だけじゃなくてこっちと驚かせるという
あるいはれた第一回はこんな感じでしたらわーっ
[音楽]
[拍手]
しています